now you're engaged again I'm engaged
again
we have to help you with these decisions
we have to protect you you're a heavy
Queen so we have to make sure that
you're with the right guy do you like
the coffee with some heavy Queen
no I met him on Bumble on Bumble yeah so
during the pandemic in Chicago I
couldn't go anywhere yeah so my gay
friend who's my stepbrother said like
darling need to go get laid wait your
gay friend is your stepbrother yeah how
does that yeah I'm doing the math yeah
so he wants to adopt me but I was too
big so he could not without me so we
became my stepsister stepbrother since
then they keep saying I'm arriving and
conservative like I'm liberal classical
level like seriously 100 I get divorced
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah women's
rights
you yeah yeah
okay this is good listen what is your
what does your Bumble account look like
yeah how come you're not on Raya lots of
questions I was on Via okay you guys
were so like creative tribes yeah and
I'm very like classical I like more like
conservative men right I like the man
who asked me out formally like I don't I
did not know going dinner was mean State
oh what did you think it was did that
wouldn't come true
[Music]
yeah and then they tried like may I he's
like what the heck are you doing like I
was so surprised because the people just
went out and I was like can I just kiss
you I was like no I said Oh I thought
you knew this was a day like no I didn't
this is actually really fun so you met
on a dating app no no no just generally
like you meet people at the conference
some dinner sometimes like okay that's a
good idea we probably dinner and they
said can I kiss you at the end of days
yes and I did not know dinner meant to
date in America no no here's the
question have you ever gone on a few
dates with a guy and he didn't kiss you
and then you started to get angry and
you had to become the empowered woman
that you are and you had to go get that
no I luckily this was my first guy from
the first person I met on Bumble oh
really yeah so and then other times when
I was on app they were like is this
really on me Park she's married you got
to be like lying you cannot do that like
yeah I got divorced but you keep I think
you know updated as fast as they could
yeah I was like faking it right so they
were like you cannot do that you cannot
lie about your ideas
leave people at all here okay so you go
on a date with your with your new with
your fiance where does he take you for
the day we went to Chicago during a
pandemic and then minus 27 Celsius not
on a date you went there no because
everything looked closed yeah and then
guys we was like do you want to come to
my place like hell no I'm not gonna read
it was like everything is closed yeah so
like then let's meet that also the tent
in the snowy freezing Chicago so we met
that and then he found warmer like
restaurant with a tents up outside
because of the pandemic everything
closed yeah yeah yeah yeah so we met at
the restaurant now is it difficult for a
guy
to complain about his life to you like
you know I love complaining about my
life to my wife ah today was difficult
you know what I mean the the bill was
late you know what I mean I stubbed my
toe does the guy feel uncomfortable
complaining to you after what you know
you've been through so my current uh
fiance is a complaint is I'm too soft on
men so much you are too soft
[Music]
look at the actual data men are
struggling we mean the modern economy
modern is also designed for women than
men actually it's better for girls
graduating from school getting office
job right yeah yeah and I'm worried as a
matter of sun like it's a bit harder for
him
and I think it's the first time he met
somebody who worrying about men's
hardship in life oh wow so I think I'm
very sympathetic why do you think men
are struggling
I think they're genetically I mean
nothing's wrong with okay even I'll
observe my son like he's a communication
skills that's not as developed as a
curse but speed is different the
maturity is different he's like fine
motor skills is different the ability to
sit down and focus is like not as good
as girls it takes a while for them to
mature up yeah and they have different I
mean I mean hormones men and women are
different I don't know why this is such
a big opinion in America right now but
culturally why do you think that there's
a struggle for young men it does seem
like that's a part of a conversation
right now that a lot of people are
having and some people are reluctant to
have so this is funny book I had a
previous agent and they were asking me
on me why don't you write a book about
how hard it is to be a woman how all
over the world is that one by men yeah
and I'm like my father died from this
dictatorship like the men are equally
more affected by these hardships yeah
not just women yeah it's not the mental
problem but I think Korean somehow
narrative in America is that men are
evil they are toxic because of the
politicians are men we have War we have
poverty way of inequality yeah so it's
hard when the world is literally against
you yeah you know they keep telling you
everything about you is toxic yeah I
mean how can you be sane even I yeah I
think I think a lot of times what
happens is that you know we see toxicity
exist within power structures and then
we look for a blame which are the people
that are in power and if the people in
power look a certain way or they're of
one gender we ascribe that blame to that
gender to their looks yeah
racism and I mean 100 we are doing that
literally to men yes yeah and I think
that we would probably do it to women if
women were in power and if it was white
I mean you guys cannot like in South
Korea the agreement like the office like
okay we don't have any good environment
for us to cry and be emotional about
things so if the guy said if I look at
your eyes it's too confrontational if I
look at your chest it's like I'm
sexually harassing you did look at my
chest just right okay I mean you're a
man I can't even look at your test one
time so guys it's like walking on the
eyeshadow like they anything they do can
be a problem
so I think we are less forgiving to men
yes by three white men yes so it's like
my son he's not gonna ever be nobody
gonna be compassionate to him because
he's a half asian half-wise so screwed
do you think that he'll get half
compassion you think there'll be some
compassion for him being Asian they say
that Colombia is talking about like the
real oppression how people are still
Enslaved the slavery never ended
yes of course black lives matter and
every lives matter I hope you don't mind
saying that but like I don't know
yeah North Korean lives matter you know
I mean she's talking about old lives but
they say that you you don't know
oppression because you're a white
passing person
to your kid they would tell me oh to you
yeah they say I don't think you're white
passing I gotta be honest yeah that's
why people keep adding shading and
bronzes and to make music more tan
actually
[Laughter]
I got wrapped by several black women and
there as you can see I'm like below 80
pounds I'm much smaller than this course
yeah now
I was here very small they punched me
they took my wallet out of me whoa in
front of my son and I was trying to call
the police on them obviously anybody do
when they get corrupt yeah people on the
Street Circle me and then screaming at
me that I'm a racist because I'm gonna
call a cop on these tips you did say
they all look the same to you so maybe
you just got the wrong person this lady
punched me like I had a video of her I
was looking out of one eye at that point
[Laughter]
[Music]
even she wanted them too that's the
thing that was the thing that is are we
victim blaming we might be victim
blaming yeah that's really what it is
okay so those black women were trying to
steal your Heavies they did I mean yeah
they punched in and took my wallet away
and like 15 grand on the blooming there
and then the police got the video
footage of them using my credit card so
we caught it so I process I mean I was
doing to go with the process okay
obviously yeah like I felt bad for her
but it was almost like you know you
cannot commit a crime yes why would you
feel bad for the person
Bloomingdale's it's not food but then
she was she actually had 15 charges
already and then people were saying
there was like actual like the Revenge
crime is a huge thing in Chicago they
just come back out of prison and shoot
you
I'm so known already they can't find my
location so you had to move yeah
immediately and then you remember why
she was in prison we got here do you
have a pet did you did you get like a
dog or a cat when you came to America
she divorced him okay she got the
divorce she's not good she divorces the
man okay
marriage is yourself your very own white
man that is a [__] accomplishment you
know it is in North Korea's about to buy
like thousand pisses I did really yeah
if you if you marry a white man you
can't I mean there's no white men there
but either word buyer or whatever wasn't
he she got kids he got told churches
like old teeth got rearranged oh my
goodness yeah you don't want to marry
that guy electrifying him they were
torturing oh [__] okay so back to you
though so despite all of that you went
after and you hooked
a white a great white as they call them
yeah yeah did you
do
oh
it was Arab so I was like are you Arab
he's like no I'm not that's right the
Iranians they don't they they believe
that they're from the caucus mountains
yeah some available did you date any
Koreans before you never dated
never made it along really and just
I just I'm just sorry but it just feels
like I'm with my own uh say it say it no
but yeah yeah yeah
is it true what they say about North
Korean men I heard they're really hung
hmm
really never I was
I was cool you don't know what sex is
you don't have a vocabulary oh you were
talking about their penis sizes yeah
yeah I heard it oh my God and there's no
North Korean porn how do you watch about
North Korean look like yeah
but then you were in South Korea I never
dated it once I don't know you didn't do
anything like that no no now are there
certain South Korean dudes that are
coming at you and they're like I was in
the university in South Korea and were
they hitting on you non-stop what did
they say what do they say well it's very
sweet I'm always like in the library so
they're like he makes like math you know
questions I know the answer to this like
the you know I don't know what your
number might be
wait a minute that's game right there
studying criminal justice the law in
criminal law yeah yeah yeah oh my God so
they came up with some math questions
yeah I know they were like no no I'm
good not having at all never got
attracted but then the Iranian he really
he knew how to Persians have games yeah
yeah yes yeah I think Americans like
when they came just like
uh I don't know like I think they keep
saying like you know that I just if you
don't hear about these stereotypes you
don't know them so there's no any
preconception in you it's very great
things it can just start like everything
is fresh everything's fresh you remember
for the first time I did not know Iran
was not Arab like right I thought they
were all like Muslims you know and he's
like no he's pork so oh interesting
Christian dated a black guy
you never got hit on by a black guy no
well you got hit on by a black woman but
that's a very different
so so you never had a black guy approach
you at all no just white guys and Asians
and then one Iranians
love it huh why is that similar history
they do I think there's like a
connectivity right there yeah oh maybe
we've been through Holocaust like if we
are going to Modern Day Hollow because
they've been throughout your heart
exactly you've dealt it you also have
the pressure the family pressure
study study yeah yeah yeah yeah but you
never got what the Jewish guy though you
never you don't date a Jewish I had the
first boyfriend that was you who was a
Russian Jew by the way
you went back to the Soviets yeah
it was like very conservative very
conservative libertarian like not like a
Christian concert like we're libertarian
libertarian so he believed in the
freedom free market individual liberty
competition like it like yeah don't tax
me yeah
he was rich
he wanted to be the government isn't
that evil it just they want a lot of
money I think that's more the philosophy
right greedy yeah because if the
government was the exact same but they
wanted no money I think there's a lot of
Libertarians it'd be like yeah this
government's fine everything's working
out yeah
I love them but Mike Mike is uh I love
Mike I love him too yeah but he believes
in chaos exactly
literally no border no military no
government I'm like I don't want to be
in that country
neutered as he
is easy to say that but then when it
happens it's like oh [__] yeah because
he's first
we're not letting that happen anymore
we like the government protecting from
that okay and your strong Iranian
husband to be yeah in the very near
future in your future yeah oh and
becoming American yeah no yeah you are
really becoming an American woman yeah
they say average woman gets married
around 34 35 in New York yeah how old
are you 22 when I was 22 I got married
but you're like Korean 22 so that's like
44 or something this is an age
difference yeah the math doesn't matter
remember you said like you're born and
then you're different
so I'm 29
in Korea in American age oh so you're 31
in Korea yeah what how old are you I'm
39. so you're 41. damn
you're in your 40s
I'm killing it right now dude
right now okay this is this is very this
is very I like this part of your life
where you're enjoying yourself you're
out there